hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry welcome
two reasons to see where we give you
reasons to see and not to see the Last
Exorcism Part 2 so let's get exercised
after escaping the cult from the first
movie Nell Sweetzer now tries to lead a
normal life but is haunted by the demon
from the previous film and this time the
demon has an even worse plan for her he
wants the [ __ ]
Ryan's consensus there are some reasons
to see the Last Exorcism Part 2 there
are some reasons to see the Last
Exorcism Part 2
yeah I have a strong Catholic upbringing
so when it comes to this supernatural
religious haunting type of stuff no
matter how a week the film is they all
scared the living [ __ ] out of me series
consensus uh as much as it pains me to
say this there's maybe one reason to see
this movie there's maybe one reason to
see the Last Exorcism Part two you know
I really like the first movie I wanted
to like this one and it just it never
did anything for me I feel bad and
saying it all those reason to see number
one Ashley Bell I thought Ashley Bell
did a good job on playing Nell she's
really entertaining to watch and besides
being entertained by her performance I
believed her struggle you know she's
this girl that comes from this farm life
who had an exorcism performing her
because there was a demon in spite of
her she's got a [ __ ] up past and now
she's trying to lead a normal life and
so she has a hard job with this role I
mean that's a lot to tackle and you know
this person who's suffering from her
past or maybe is it a demon that's
haunting her it's it's a lot to do and I
thought she did a very good job on it
there's a lot of layers to the
performance and I thought she did a good
job of layering it yeah you know I
I like Ashley Bell a lot and I think she
does a good job and you know she's you
just want to give her a hug a lot of the
time you know cuz you know that she's
lived a very sheltered life you know
just she's a simple farm girl and now
she's again put in a completely
different world I like her and I bought
her for the most part I feel like
anything the film succeeds that with
with Nell especially is pretty much a
credit to her just because I was so
sympathetic towards her so you know I
think she's good there there are some
moments just because of the way that
sweet farm girl delivery is there are
some moments where the movie doesn't
quite match and then some of her
dialogue sounds a bit weird but overall
and especially in the D many moments I
think she doesn't really gel reasons not
to see the effects I think the one thing
I can agree on with you is the effects
of this film are not the greatest
there's there's a moment where there's a
lot of fire and it it does look very
even though I actually like that scene
yeah it's a good seeing I shot really
cool too yeah but the fire didn't look
really fake and you'll know what I'm
talking about when you watch it it did
look surprisingly fake yes yeah I almost
don't understand this movie in terms of
like what they must have done with their
budget few of these scenes have any
effects that are like complicated and
then on top of that they're CG so I'm
like why didn't you you could have just
done some actual fire you know and yeah
and then it would have been fine so I
don't I don't really get what whoever
did the effects was going for exactly
yeah they look like me back a little bit
split decision number one writing and
directing I like the way the characters
were written not all the characters but
I especially like the way Nell was
written I I thought they had a lot of
dimension to bring for her that allowed
her to give such a good performance you
know I it's not fully met with its
potential I I can admit that the film is
mainly ideas and that are halfway met
but I respected the ideas and I enjoyed
watching the ideas even though they're
not
with the most potential that it could
have been executed that yeah I mean
that's that's what I can give this movie
is sort of if I were gonna rewrite this
movie I wouldn't change any of the ideas
I don't think because it's very
different from the first one but I like
that like it has lots of really good
concepts that I feel like it
didn't do much of anything with in my
earning degrees I disagree I thought you
know watching the ideas unfold like with
her exploring you know what it might be
like to have a boyfriend what it might
be like you know like getting the sexual
you know vibes from her her learning
about friendship
all these other layers that they brought
to it and allowed the movie to be more
enhanced when I was watching I feel like
some of those things got off to a good
start
some of them didn't and nothing ever
fully realized yeah nothing anything
nothing becomes fully tied in nothing
becomes fully realized but at the end of
the day you know it's it's to me it was
just another low-budget horror film and
I enjoyed it even though I really do
respect the first one a lot I love the
first one I think it's a great film just
an overall it's not just a good horror
film it's a good film and this one I
just looked at it as a low-budget horror
flick and as far as a little bunch of
horror flick goes I I enjoy I enjoyed it
throughout yeah I mean the problem is
I've seen so many other low-budget
horror flicks recently I don't try to
compare it to them but there's a lot
we've proven lately especially what you
can do with the low budget and I sort of
feel like this movie they have like four
sets and you know a couple cameras and
then they just made people stare at each
other for a while because like every the
the structure is like people stare then
people walk then something spooky
happens then rinse repeat
I get what they're going for but it's
like they didn't have any guts to go
anywhere with it they just said here's a
bunch of neat ideas now really carries
this movie the character of now carries
this on top of that with the performance
of actually bail so to see the camera
just pretty much let the actor do the
job and let her carry the movie i SPECT
that it was kind of like watching eight
even though there's several characters
in it it was kind of like watching a
one-man show you
except to me that didn't feel like a
directorial choice as much of as much as
it felt like a lack of directorial
anything you didn't find it to be like a
character study in a way cuz I'd be this
sort of like a character study of now I
felt like it wanted to be a character
study and it should have been a
character study but it didn't really
study that much like it it said like
she's yeah kind of just floors it a
little bit but it doesn't fully meet it
it's basically somebody wrote you a
letter home saying oh yeah and I was
doing okay she's kind of seeing this
dude now she's got a job she's had an
episode of her now and again but will
write back later it's like well I'm like
I totally get your point and I just saw
ideas on screen that I respected I
didn't expect those ideas to be there in
this movie so I respect what they were
trying to do and see how I find what I
have to admit though is this I had no
expectations for this tone even though
these types of films always scare the
crap out of me I am really didn't
because I have nothing but horrible
things about it so I think if you have
no expectations for this movie I think
you'll find it to be an OK film but if
you have even a smidgen of expectations
I think you'll be let down yeah I didn't
go in with huge expectations but I did
go in thinking like it's probably not as
badly I expected I would enjoy myself
yeah yeah I mean the film is flawed they
don't they don't tie in a lot of this
stuff to the first one they don't
explain things that they tease that at
the end of the first one so it's not the
best of sequels for sure
no and a lot better those the movie
feels like it leaves all the actors
holding the stick it's just every scene
sort of feels like I do something you
know I didn't feel that way and you have
Austin to feel that way
horror director Eli Rock but then again
he produced this film a split decision
number two the horror definitely all the
jump scares in this movie and all the
horror parts of it we're just going
remember how cool the last movie was
yeah half the jump scares are clips for
the first book at the end that just come
at random with a loud noise yeah I mean
the jump scripts are cheap but they made
me jump so I did jump a couple times but
again it was one of those it's like and
I'm not comparing it to this movie but
like paranormal like 73 is a lot of
cheap jump scares but every time they
them I was like oh you guys like you're
having some fun with this at least and
this one it was just like something
normal is happening for the first movie
I like the mood of it you know like the
directing I thought with it you know
created tension for me see that was that
was my other problem is that is the tone
of the movie felt like it was one thing
the entire time like even the characters
the story the tone
nothing ever breached just a simmer
well the tone changes when Nell has
having change in her levels of emotion
yeah she's the only thing that changes
in this movie because every character
has the same reaction to everything
everyone just stares at stuff I feel
like the camera is just staring that
same blank stare everybody gives in this
movie but I thought the horror was
effective because they was layered with
other stuff I guess I mean I guess if it
was just that one I didn't find it to be
just that one tone I felt the tone
changed whenever and depending on Nell's
mood I guess but see horror like getting
a heart right up and scaring people it
all sort of rides on hope versus fear
and how much you like these people and
it's like I never thought that anybody
would be able to figure this out or
vanquish this demon because the script
never allows for anybody to get any
headway it's just like the demon bosses
them around for a while and then it ends
like I never believed anybody could
fight this guy and so it killed all the
horror for me because I was like it's
all going one direction and it doesn't
seem to try and convince me otherwise
like see I like the horror because the
focus is Nell and Ashley Bell does a
good job with it
so I don't want the demon to win and
because I don't want the demon to win
I was scared whenever it seemed like the
demon was going to win see the only time
I ever got scared her or any anything
that was just was only because I like
Ashley I will say there's a scene where
it looks like a demon's gonna go into
chicken we almost got the chicken demon
we did not get that chicken demon
alright guys thanks for watching you
could go ahead and tell us your reasons
to see or not to see the Last Exorcism
Part 2 and if you want to hear my
straight to-the-point review of the last
exorcism part ii go ahead and click on
this link below and if you want to see
more reasons to see reviews click on
this link right below and if you want to
get the whole real rejects experience or
just get updated whenever a new review
is out go ahead and subscribe right
there subscribe or else the demon will
haunt you what would you do tell us
below what would you do if a demon
wanted to [ __ ] you yeah demon sex what
are your thoughts might be crazy might
be a wild ride
you might float in the air might be an
experienced man you might catch like a
sulfur-based STD - oh god that would
suck what if a demon gave you an STD
there's probably no way to treat it yeah
no it's just turns like whatever part of
your body that is into rock yeah I mean
which is smoldering rock freeze to be
able to get rid of the STD I mean how
would you get rid of the STD tell us
below think about walking up YouTube we
went to a priest for that yeah like hey
oh yeah I can't explain this away I had
sex with a demon father it's been 4
years since my last confession
well what do you have to confess about I
had sex with a demon yeah I think God's
pretty much written you off son yeah
you're going to hell next
you